das ist gut schon früh malt er
leidenschaftlich gerne um seine familie
durchzubringen
in er einen job bei einer bank an eines
tages crash die börse ag verliert seinen
job nicht gerade unglücklich darüber
widmet er sich ganz der malerei
er träumt von exotischen orten von
inspiration für seine bilder siedelt
nach tahiti
die kinder und seine frau lässt er
zurück die familie muss ohne
zurechtkommen buga wird erst nach seinem
tod so richtig berühmt
seine bilder werden für millionen
verkauft er wird als held gefeiert als
einer der seiner leidenschaft folgte und
seinem talent ausdruck verlieh dass er
seine frauen seine kinder im stich ließ
wird als gerechtfertigt angesehen
doch was wäre wenn gucker keinen erfolg
gehabt hätte und sein werk
entdeckt worden wäre
würden wir es einfach halten dann auch
rechtfertigen